community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
the findlay automotive group the
sponsors of this next segment has many
leaders within the group that are giving
back to the community and that includes
our community of furry friends take a
look
[Music]
tyler it is great to see you and your
furry little friend who is this this is
hashgogo from uh
yeah from the nevada spca hey buddy
how's it going oh my gosh adorable
finley automotive group you guys are
always giving back to our community but
it's more than just monetary donations
that you guys are doing yeah exactly so
we uh we like to get our people involved
we do a lot of volunteer events and so
forth with a lot of non-profits in town
we also try to get our people on boards
and serve and really make a meaningful
impact with some of the charities so uh
so today we're featuring the nevada spca
hence the kitty cat the kitty cat we're
over at subaru of las vegas and so i'm
going to introduce you in a moment to
jennifer vitale who's our assistant
general manager here at findlay subaru
of las vegas because she serves on the
board of the nevada spca we can talk a
little bit about what they do awesome
i'll follow you and follow the kitty cat
all right let's go oh
[Music]
so jc this is jennifer i want to
introduce you to her and uh here you go
here's hashtag thank you tyler hi
jennifer how are you
i'm good how are you oh my gosh who's
that this is cherry okay so how did you
get involved in the nevada spca well
from subaru las vegas you know we're
just involved in the community one of
the pillars is super love's pets and so
naturally the relationship was built
there and anytime i walked into the
facility it just was a lot of joy and
happiness and i love pets i love animals
so it was a natural fit for me what is
so what are your responsibilities over
there um i serve on the board so
anything honestly that i can help with
um is really what i'm there for whatever
they have needs with whether it's
helping set up with their
fundraisers or helping introduce
different corporate organizations to
them for support just anything and
everything that they need help with i'm
there for and we know that subaru loves
pets we can hear the dogs barking in the
background we actually have a pet area
outside the pet area inside here we do
we have a dog park outside for all the
dogs that come on over they can take a
break and uh just run around in the dog
park out there and then we have pet bowl
we have a pet sink we have snacks for
the dogs so it's endless it certainly is
and yeah you love pets and you love the
car industry you're a leader in the car
industry what advice would you have for
a young and up-and-comer who wants to
get involved in the automotive industry
yeah i would say you know never give up
on your dreams just keep putting one
foot in front of the other and
remember to give back you know along the
way remember to give back that's really
important i love it i love it this and
by the way look at hashgogo i think i
think he's ready to go play in the pen
ready to go play
why don't we take our flights or pets
and go play that sounds great sounds
good i'll follow you all right
come on buddy let's go
such a cute cat if you're interested in
adopting a pet head over to
nevadaspca.org or call them at 702-8736
las vegas now we will be right back